let's go next to our caller from the 706
area code who is calling today from 7:06
hey David this is Kyle from Orlando
Florida hey Kyle what's up hey um so I
work for Disney and as part of our union
contract we were able to get $15 an hour
by 2021 right which i think is great but
you know in 2016 we were having the
debate about $15 being the minimum wage
but you know given that inflation is a
thing shouldn't we be talking more about
$20 an hour now and tying that to
inflation yeah so this is something I've
mentioned many times
well when the $15 an hour minimum wage
thing started and it was often not for
right now but let's get up to $15 by
some future date a lot of the outre a
lot of the outrage was just bad faith
outrage some of the outrage seemed not
to take into account that merely because
of inflation it would have really only
been like $12 at the time that the
conversation started or $13 at the time
that you know the conversations been
going on with a lot of different be tied
to inflation automatically because
otherwise this conversation will
literally never end right right
do you I mean do you think of like
shooting for $20 an hour anyways and
then I mean maybe we can say I will the
compromise will be you know $15 an hour
just as a way to I guess to get ahead of
the Republicans I don't know that I
would just throw out a random number but
there are good studies that say listen
if we had indexed to inflation going
back to 1968 it should now be you know
like 1770 an hour that's where it should
be let's negotiate from there and and
here's something and now a lot of people
on the right won't won't like that but
let me say something that a lot of
people on the Left won't like which i
think does make sense I've said before I
think that the minimum wage needs to be
regionalised to some degree because if
you have a low cost of living state
where you're talking about going from
750 to 15 that is very different than a
high cost of living state where you're
talking about
from 12 to 15 so I do think that there
is something to we should look at I
don't know if it's on a state-by-state
level metro areas or whatever the case
may be but there should be consideration
given to both cost of living as well as
what the current minimum wage is I'm not
advocating for the wage to be 725
anywhere to be clear but I am saying
that in some places 15 may not actually
be the right number to achieve what it
is that that we should be looking to
achieve okay well thanks David all right
appreciate the call thank you so much